i have loved every single time i played
the character this is ten years now have
the opportunity to do another one it's
just mind-blowing we'll be hammering out
all the spicy details of chris
hemsworth's nudity scene christian
bale's intense transformation into gore
the god butcher and everything we've got
on the hours of deleted scenes
number one
obviously we have to talk about chris
hemsworth stripping down here
according to taika ytt everyone at the
fox studios really wanted to catch a
glimpse of this already iconic scene
every single person decided oh i needed
to come in and get people's invoices for
work
about
350 people came to set that day and most
of them had never dared to step foot on
set before we see you fox studios we see
you
number two
christian bale has undergone an
impressive array of transformations
throughout his career so we were super
excited to find out about his portrayal
of gore the god butcher christian
doesn't hesitate to give credit to the
team who created that look every morning
i collaborated with absolutely brilliant
makeup artists to
create this character he spends four
hours in the makeup chair at the start
of the day and a half hour at the end if
you're familiar with gore's character in
the comics you would know he looks
considerably different from the way he
looks in the film when i first met taika
he'd already said no no that's not the
way that he wants to go with it part of
that decision was because of christian
himself i was coming off of another film
where i'd had to be sort of absolutely
void of any muscles whatsoever number
three now let's talk about the scene
that might have been a bit too graphic
for this family-friendly mcu film in an
interview with ign christian bale
explains how gore is a very religious
character who in the beginning has some
prominent tattoos displaying his
religious devotion the tattoos that they
have are all like you know in reverence
and in honor of the gods but eventually
he ends up mutilating himself in order
to remove them we did shoot that it was
perhaps a little bit too extreme to be
included in the film though he says
there was a lot of great content in that
shot everyone just found the scene a bit
too extreme christian explained
some things can work some things don't
and we want this to be a family film you
know my kids love it number four
speaking of family friendly a fun fact
to look out for when you're watching the
movie is that most of the actors kids
have roles in the film
our kids are in the film yeah christians
kids are in the film natalie's kids are
in the film it's just cheap labor tyka's
kids are insanely tough critics not an
easy bunch to impress
you're going to do this all day long
[ __ ] the clothes don't look real enough
and the brakes are too short number five
taika waititi and chris hemsworth have
worked together for such a long time you
can't deny the chemistry they have as a
duo parker he's like a big kid it's like
sort of a genius child
so of course tyka is going to have some
revolutionary notes on chris's
performance
don't do it like that again or i'd be
like oh can i try something here because
sure if it's better than my writing
great do it when they were mixing the
sound the actors had to re-record a good
handful of lines because taika wouldn't
stop laughing in the background
through some of our best takes he's just
laughing in the background over the top
of all of it number six
this wouldn't be a love and thunder
video without some goat talk look at
those they are wonderful yes they are
they also scream quite a lot something
you might not know about these goats is
yes they are created with vfx but during
the actual shoot the actors got to have
practical goat sculptures to react to
they weren't actual animal goats they
were practical kind of sculptures that
we had on set with us chris hemsworth
had a bit of an inkling as to who would
end up voicing these manic wild goats
i can only assume because i don't know
for certain that it's taka doing the
voices of the guts
number seven
in the film natalie portman's character
jane is six foot three though natalie
herself is only five foot three in order
to practically get her to rise to that
height the crew built decks for her to
walk on when she would have walking
scenes there'd be like risers that she
would be on and they'd be like okay
bring in the deck for natalie number
eight unsurprisingly chris hemsworth and
taika ytt love to go off script in true
taika waititi style we go off the page
and he sits behind the camera and
giggles obviously we would love to see
some of this improv but of course taika
doesn't give himself enough credit
probably one of the worst films ever
made
the eight hour vision
number nine who's making an appearance
in this movie
it's the big question everyone wants the
answer to before the film actually comes
out
there are definitely cameos well before
the movie did premiere tyco kept all the
cameos under lock and key but he did
give us a little snippet of crucial
information i'll give this away there
are some from the last film that were
coming back and if we're being honest
essentially a lot of the cameos are
friends of the cast and crew who's
around who's in town who wants to come
and play for a day or two for not much
money number 10. did you know there are
at least two hours of unseen footage
that was cut from the movie chris
hemsworth describes it as an assembling
of madness really like about five times
it just gives up on the story and just
like 10 15. the story was sacrificed
from the way tyka and chris talk about
it they essentially sacrificed drawn out
scenes and jokes for a strong structural
story natalie portman though was sad to
see a lot of the scenes go incredible
hilarious
moving comedy and drama
ends up not there
like natalie we also pray that some of
this footage ends up being released as
bonus features there are so many things
in there i mean one day it will it
should be we need a director to cut
number 11
there is some great bro chemistry
between taika and chris so much in fact
that taika commemorated his time on set
with a very special tattoo it would say
i love ch and i did that tattoo that's
how i commemorated my time with you yeah
number 12
because of all the vigorous training the
cast had to go through to prep for this
movie they would often take ice baths to
revitalize their muscles and energy but
once you get out you feel awake and
you're i don't know it's great when
tessa thompson heard about how hard it
was for all the guys on set she decided
to turn it into a competition chris was
like oh i finally got up to two minutes
or three minutes i was like i'm gonna
get up to four to this day tessa is
still the reigning ice bath champion
number 13. taika waititi was known to
make daily changes to the script i think
it must be frustrating working with me
maybe
the actors would come in and he'd hand
them a completely new draft to work with
oh sorry
there's all these changes i've made
eventually they just decided they
wouldn't even bother to learn their
lines before coming in and i think the
actors eventually just kind of gave up
number 14.
natalie portman found christian bale's
presence as gore to be so powerful that
she had to overcome quite a bit of fear
to do scenes with him she was buff and
every time i had any scene with her she
was angry but unbeknownst to her
christian felt the same way she was
focused and she had a hell of a presence
and i was bloody intimidated by her
number 15.
taika really wanted the love aspect of
floor love and thunder to be prominent
in a way that it could be considered a
romantic comedy i guess the influences
for me were
really big over-the-top romances one of
the films that inspired him was an
officer and a gentleman particularly the
final scene what i can think of is like
anything with a bob sega
thor love and thunder is full of action
comedy and a ton of heart from this
dedicated cast and crew taiko ytt is
clearly putting his own fresh spin on
the fourth installment of this two
billion dollar franchise
which part of the process were you most
intrigued by